oh no
people are gonna be dropping some uh
love you long times potentially I'm sure
it'll be super stereotypical any like
coded language for an Asian person I
expect to find someone just looking at
these titles it already looks pretty
terrible yeah
let's watch this the Asian babies that
are scared you know what's funny is like
I like don't like kids that much so
every time I was an Asian babysitter I
was really scared this angle also oh my
God she's upside down like this woman's
in her 20s she's dressed like a little
girl and she has like pigtails like up
to here with like a baby tall crop top
and like shorts he's treating her like a
child oh God he just like he just lost
yeah he pushed her down and then just
put
she basically made a night stick
innuendo but she did it bad oh no
oh putting his lights uh like the actual
night's thing on his dick Sharon Lee
maid who knows how to please okay so now
there's like this Asian maid she doesn't
speak English and she just says sex I
don't want sex
no attempts right now I'm like oh I
think it's plunged
I haven't seen one Asian guy in this too
I realize that it's only been like Asian
women and white men
speaking Japanese I just like open her
legs like don't go she was just speaking
English earlier it was like it's happy
ending my Asian massage girl why is it
why are you giving us old men yeah now
the masseuse is naked but the client is
not which makes no sense the mature and
responsible old man with the horny and
uncontrollable like Asian woman
essentially is what's happening
oh
on the walls of this house there's a lot
of like old Asian men with like buns in
like Warrior clothing
he sounds like an animal also she didn't
finish
that's not fair
it wasn't enjoyable to watch really I
was expecting like we have Asian guy and
Asian girls
oh no I I completely expected Asian
girls oh really if you don't grow up in
like a diverse area and you're only
exposed to Asian women like through your
media or through your porn like you're
gonna have a super warped idea of what
it means to be an Asian woman and you're
also probably going to think that Asian
men just don't exist
[ __ ] racist porn only do nice porn